alright I'm coming to you live from a
Nissan Sentra about 20 miles from the
nearest Internet I am wearing on I'm
safe with saying Mayo capri pants I've
been sharing a room with a dog named
Sophie could be a chihuahua I know it's
small not a dog really in my eyes but
you know modern man calls it a dog to me
if a if a frisbee will kill it not a dog
and right now looking outside of this
window this Nissan select or something I
can see probably about 1100 fireflies
these are up to something
you know they're going to rebel they're
going to maybe start an actual fire I
wouldn't be surprised if something or
someone burns tonight I'm in Wyoming
Illinois and welcome to this past
weekend this past weekend let's do it
you ready you ready to support the
podcast I'm going to tell you right now
that Dollar Shave Club is the smarter
choice what are you doing huh you're
still just having one razor you got to
keep track of all the time maybe you're
putting your your out-of-town bag maybe
you didn't maybe your son's cutting up
cocaine in the next room with it who
knows I don't know don't worry about it
anymore you don't have to with the
Dollar Shave Club it's a smarter choice
you get a great shave at a great price
conveniently delivered right to your
door knock knock who's there
razor blade it's an awesome life hack
it's a no-brainer
you got to you got a call that that that
that lawn off your face
you could spend a fortune on razors with
gimmicky shaving techniques you don't
need number the one that came up and had
the battery in it what the hell is that
nothing nothing so I use my Dollar Shave
Club executive razor with the dr.
Carver's shave butter woo
I love butter the blade is gently jerk
just just glides across my face give me
such a smooth shave oh I am a bald eagle
that's what they say and uh you know and
a lot of ladies say then with that bald
eagle you know so for a limited time new
members get their first month of the
executive razor with a tubular dr.
Carver's shave butter for only five
dollars with free shipping
after that razors are just a few bucks a
month it's a fifteen dollar value for
only five bucks you can only get this
offer exclusively at dollarshaveclub.com
slash weekend
that's the dollarshaveclub.com slash
weekend hit it guys support the podcast
there's a trial basis going there and
here to get some razors man get some
razors I'm going to stay in the program
I'm gonna keep it going
dollarshaveclub.com slash weekend
[Music]
we'll be there
July third baby celebrate always so but
everything all your dreams will come to
life celebrate a living right there that
is the Spencer Jacob grab and we'll put
the link to that in the YouTube you can
check it out thank you guys for joining
me on this past weekend it is Monday
July 3rd I'm coming to you live or
however people come to each other over
there over a podcast from a Nissan from
outside of the Nissan I'm in rural
Illinois it is dark out here dude
I mean you can't you can't see nothing I
mean the devil could be just smelling
the cinnamon stains on your skin and you
wouldn't know he's right next to you
you know and I'm coming to you live from
a Nissan because this is the rental deal
I got you know that bait and switch
there on the picture on the rental it
looks like more of a you know full
fuller car chariot type you know
something full-bodied you know but then
I get there and the lady said well you
know it's optional and using all these
buzz words and kill words words that
killed what I wanted which is more of a
full-bodied vehicle you feel me but
whatever that's life good to be here man
happy 4th of July week now this may be
on YouTube it may not I can't guarantee
that guys and because look I came out
here I had big dreams get read big
dreams huh for a weekend you ever go and
you pack I want me to do this I'm going
to bring the the piano
did I used to bring the piano learning
booklets oh yeah oh I'm staying at a
Hampton Inn in Norfolk Virginia sure the
probably of a piano down the lobby I'll
practice a little I'm gonna be there for
five days I'll practice
yeah I'll brush up on the keys I'm
amazed to bring so much with me
unbelievable they might have struck junk
I'll bring on the road now I don't even
want to bring my luggage I'd rather just
read the same if they made a shirt
that fought back every morning to look
the same way it did the night before you
know a shirt that kind of took care of
itself I you were sleeping they could
kind of brush itself up and kind of get
that dirt off its shoulders and it's a
shirt that had a little more self-care
so you don't have to wash it at all
that's what I would win you know I just
don't want to bring everything with me
anymore huh but anyhow I got to tell you
man I'm out here in Stark County
Illinois
alright we did the show I want to thank
everybody I had some fans that drove out
and friends that drove out five hours
from Evansville Indiana
I had a squad that came in from
Milwaukee and Milwaukee I don't know if
you guys know that that's a beer town
and it's also it's a Indian term a lot
of people forget that these a lot of our
cities and towns are named after the
very Native Americans that we beat him
up beat him off of you know Milwaukee
Las Vegas I think the Las Vegas were a
tribe who else
the Toledo the Toledo they were a tribe
you know I mean it's just it's almost
crazy that we kept the same names for a
lot of places just rub it in their faces
you know but uh but I'm out here in
rural Illinois we had a great show we
raised almost $7,500
for a theater here that's huge in this
town and I got to tell you what I say
rule I mean you can't if you have AT&T
you can't don't you can't have it here
they don't have that you got to stop in
town in some local spot and get the
local service whatever it is some it's
basically it's boomers it's like just
heightened rumors you know that's how
people communicate with each other you
got to tell somebody then they go tell
somebody else you want to get in touch
that's a text message around here it's
small then I'm right now I'm within a
hundred yards of probably six or seven
horses and a pony I saw a pony on the
way in there's a little rabbits
everywhere a little Disney
animals you know I mean there's probably
a couple of Care Bears right now
in the distance that's where I'm at
I am rural out here I got two video
cameras set up in a Nissan and
somebody's driveway out here this good
family let me sleep out here in their
room where they got a bunch of hunting
guns and there are four dead animals in
the room I'm sleeping and they got the
heads up them up on the walls you know
you forget that you know I live out in
LA if you put the head of anything on
the wall unless it's a straight white
male then let you let you decapitate one
of those whether you put the head of
anything else on the wall
I mean I'll arrest you you know then
we'll have a gun to arrest you with
Fidel arrest you but I'm rule I'm rule
laughs flew out here from Los Angeles
flew in the st. Louis I'll try to play a
nice diner on the way up here you know
it's hard to find a nice diner you got
to excuse me if our voice is a little
bit out of it
just I mean I'm out here I'm out in the
elements basically the bear grylls of
electronics out here
and I flew out here flew to st. Louis
trying to find a nice diner took the red
I finally found a place you know drove
like 40 miles it was a three-hour drive
to this town in Illinois where we did
so the fundraiser finally find a spot I
get in go sit down the raising Charlotte
you know she said she'd spent the whole
weekend with her boyfriend she's about
probably about 63 still got some nice
hips on her there's still got a you know
some high ass you know that's one thing
that uh you want in a woman is you want
to mount a little bit of ass left as
they get older so ladies if you're
getting up in years you know keep some
ass or get some you know stack something
in the top of your pants
Malaysia stuffed my underwear that night
because I they had I started having wet
dreams you know when I was a child
because God if you don't meet women God
start sending your women in your dreams
to kind of you know pleasure you off and
make you feel joy and you're down in
your crotch and I'm you know your brain
in your crotch it's really there's some
ol taneous organs you know when it comes
to sexual desires they're really it's a
duet between the two and Isis so maybe
bizarre I just stuffed my pants with our
t-shirts to make my crotch look bigger
so that I would get you know more
attractive women or more well breasted
woman's in my dream that come and spend
time with me and be sexual so I used to
always put a t-shirt in my crotch at
night and we only got one of those damp
dreams or the wet dreams they call them
you know kind of yeah you'd have a
little seizure in the middle of the
night out of your crotch and kind of
spray up you know and that would ah and
you wake up in the morning and feel you
know you'd be disappointed a dream
wasn't real but you also felt like he
kind of got something to sleep a little
bit and it was nice you know especially
when I was you know 12 or 13 it was a
nice respite from not getting any
because I didn't really get in a sexual
contact I was about you know actual sex
so about 15 16 maybe something so anyhow
what am I talking about
Oh slice it stuffed in front of my pants
or a prettier women we're coming meet me
in my dreams
you know you were young it was all you
had this idea that you never you had to
be you know stout in the crotch or
really have a thick Gible down there you
know that anyhow yes sir ladies I say if
you're gonna stuff something as you get
older I so you stuck the back of your
pants with some ass some type of ass
meat or something cuz that that I think
some of these ladies a butt start to
fall a little and it's okay if I might
you know saying you can't ever fallen I
ass but you throw a couple of t-shirts
back there you know stack one on each
side chic and I think that'll keep you
in business with some men if you still
looking to you know obtain some general
from another man and as you grow older
but anyhow I'm out here in rural
Illinois I stopped at a diner is Lady
Charlotte she said she spent the weekend
with her boyfriend and you know I was
like I didn't care about all that I
sling some breakfast and she was you
know just insinuating that she'd been
sensual all weekend and look you're 62
years old Lane I think it's good you
know I think it's going to be achieving
at those days but you know she kept
saying she was doing timeless activities
and I'm guessing she meant sex you know
I don't know what else you know I don't
know what else is time you know I don't
know anyway whatever but the breakfast
order to find this good diner total
a couple of biscuits at any any
lumberjack could have made anybody
with a bag of flour and a and a throat
full of phlegm put a whip together these
biscuits and then I'm just a can of just
gravy
just ass you know gravy you get
off the shelf some type of meat bits in
and some cheese and some just America
just you know it made me wonder is that
American dream diners it's still out
there am I just crazy did I pick a bad
spot you know it just pissed me off
really cuz I here think about Charlotte
you know out there getting their frickin
Gibble's wiggled and then finally when I
get my food I'm taking the red-eye I'm
dusty and nasty and it's a bunch of dang
just it's a damn garbage plate you know
which is just so anyhow they didn't
start off good my
experience here in the in the end of the
environment here but I got to this town
man and I got to the town of Wyoming
took about three hours we raise $7,500
we had two shows and man it was cool man
I got to tell you the people in this
town in Wyoming really showed up this is
a small town when talking 1,400 people
we're talking one flashing red light
American flags everywhere you know just
a you know a lot of god-fearing people
some wood questions for sure you know as
we evolved there's a lot more questions
when it comes to faith for sure and you
know deities across the board people are
questioning but but good people and they
came out they supported the theater that
you know nobody had been in in 20 years
I saw my first filming and here we were
performing and raising some money in
that theater and I'm going to put some
pictures up on to on the Facebook you
want to check out some of the weekend
try to make a video to from it but it
was magical man it was really magical
just the kind of theater has a big the
big you know bright light kind of
old-fashioned paramount kind of with the
with the what are those yellow and green
light the bars about light you have they
see the bars they look like gas or
something in the I don't know my
brain just keeps just seem like I'm
brain just wet its own bed just now
anyhow a good time people came out we
raised some good money sure they're
going to be able to hopefully keep the
air on his feet for a while and maybe
we'll come back next year and do it we
have some other comedians that drove in
people came in from all over man and we
made it happen
so thank you I want to thank everybody
that came but this is a small town dude
I'm talking you know the Mayor was out
there and he's drinking and you know
people are out there and just rumors and
you know a lot of uh I mean this is a
town you got rabbits and you got people
I haven't heard of a lot of newfangled
stuff and family first you know that
kind of thing and just a lot of people
that kind of believe in that American
ideal that old-fashioned
you know red white and blue you know we
we love our family and our you know the
dad you know mostly make some money and
some of the women would work as well but
some are more at home just caring for
their children are volunteering around
town where they can help in the
community and it's just that kind of
environment you know a lot of horses and
graveyards that are just open no fences
on people's yards you are to connect
right to the neighbor's yard so you know
there's a lot more right next door to
each other a lot of swimming bowling
people stand up at night in the kitchen
and chatting together and just being
together they still have you know fun
stuff Netflix and drugs and all that but
but there's definitely more of a family
element more of a community a sense of
community a lot of churches around you
know decent amount of people if you
might still go to church and I hadn't
been in this kind of environment in a
long time you know I mean this is even
smaller than the town that I grew up in
this is it's just small there's crops
everywhere I mean I saw a million years
of corn this weekend you know we also
went out to some we went on some drag
race had trucks out there pulling each
other and it's called a truck and
tractor-pull and that was amazing I've
never seen this but it's just people
burning gasoline out in the distance and
everybody just spending time and getting
sunburned together but it was nice man
that may be wonder about America a
little bit you know it was predominantly
white here in town you uh you have a
couple of under them uh the guy who did
this the audio for the show was an
Indian gentleman his family's uh might
be first-generation Indian you had some
other a little bit of diversity here and
there some Latinos black some black but
otherwise mostly I mean predominantly
white area out here but there was a
strong sense of Americana you know and I
just wonder this is a question because
I'm not going to have a long episode
today guys just because it's just 40
weekend you know I'm out here I don't
know for them to be able to to upload
this so the place I'm staying that has
internet but I mean it is choppy you
know having able to use my phone out
here until we went to a fair tonight a
carnival in a neighboring town and we
went rode the roads and the rides and I
mean it was damn ratchet over there just
a bunch of straight dub TZ boy
white-trash out there just a lot of
people just spitting in the air and
catching it in their mouths you know a
lot of children with children I think I
saw an eight-year-old with two children
out there so it was that kind of
environment but I just want to what do
people think America is these days and
something's been on my mind this weekend
you know what is America what does it
mean to be a you know American anymore
does it mean anything and where did you
develop your sense of what America is
you know I thought about it growing up
my sense of America a lot of it came
from movies and television you know I
remember I talked last week about you
know seeing the movie curly sue and had
a little girl in her bed at night she
would recite the Pledge of Allegiance
before she went to bed and I remember
when I was young they had the Persian
Gulf War so you would see you'd hear a
lot of support about that like you know
support our troops you know America you
know like let's take care of our people
that sort of thing my talent kind of
small see we played baseball at it like
the VFW and the American Legion so you
were around a lot of veterans she would
hear some stories from them you know one
of them would be missing a limb or
something like that and we had Steph my
stepfather was in the Korean War or
something and a lot of people's parents
had served and were actually in actual
wars so when I my generation growing up
you would hear a lot of that there was a
lot of you know we fought and we did
this and we fought for America and then
the dream team came out when I was young
and
I was the the basketball the first
basketball olympic basketball team they
ever had as far as I knew and that was a
sense of Americana right there you know
there was also a lot of television shows
where you got this you know you
developed a sense of like American pride
from TV or from you know of having a
family and you know rosanne you know I'm
watching that and you know they would
reference America you know this is the
greatest country and you know just
things like that I'm just kind of wonder
I'm sort of wondering where - my idea of
America come from you know what did it
mean we had a teacher in our school who
was she had a couple sons who were in
the military and she was a devout
American every day in her class were in
there we would do the Pledge of
Allegiance together she taught us all
about everything about America you know
just a lot of history everything so that
was as big and what is it what did it
mean to be an American and then now what
you know what does it mean like what
does it mean these some of you guys I
just want to know I want to kind of tap
into that a little bit
you know I live in LA now and it's
different the idea of what American is
out there is different you know it has a
lot more to do with diversity like
anybody can be an American whereas in
smaller towns like this it seems to have
more to do with red white and blue you
know were and in like Los Angeles it's
more like opportunity you know anybody
can come here and make a buck and we
should never close our borders to anyone
but here it's like you know we shouldn't
open our borders maybe to people if if
if they don't have some of the same
beliefs that we have here so there's
just a lot of stuff in the artists
wonder what it means to you
these days to be an American doesn't
mean anything I wonder because it's
definitely worn off some from when I was
a child you know I forget how great
great how grateful I should be every day
now like a wake up and I could be
anything I want in this country
other freedom of speech my job is the
freedom of speech you can love whoever
you want in America you know hell you
can sit outside their window and watch
them dress and undress and feed their
cats and stuff and that's not legal but
you can do it here you know you won't
get killed you won't get be sentenced to
slaughter you know it's just we live in
a really you know I still forget to be
grateful a lot of times you know I
really do and they're kind of you know
have I forgot what it's what it means to
be an American I'm starting to take it
for granted you know I don't know has it
been just because there's so long since
we've had a war or a battle that's
really been on people's mind and it's
affected people you know we're so
divided these days it's it's mostly uh
you know middle class and lower class
people whose children are serving in
these wars well you have a lot of upper
class people who wouldn't then let their
children enlist you know whose children
don't need to enlist to survive to make
money to provide for a family to get
benefits they don't have to do that so
you have you know I mean I wonder what
what percentage of the 1% in America
make sense of the wealth what percentage
of their family are in military you know
it just makes you know just it's
interesting how probably we have
different opinions in different places
what it means to be an American
you know I mean it's tough these days
because you want to have a sense of
pride so whenever that sense of pride
when I was a young but they make you
feel bad as this vibe in the air where
you know if you if you wrote if you fly
an American flag that you're there's
something wrong with you you're a
redneck more than you are proud you know
they're the yura you're not open to
everyone you're not diverse enough just
because I don't you just because you
want to fly your own home country flag
you know when I see out here in this
small town man I have to tap the homes
in this town have an American flag out
front
you know just makes me think it's just
what does it mean anymore you know and
it feels kind of nice a little bit -
these people have a kind of a simpler
way of life it's not bad it's nice it's
almost nice the house that I'm at I
don't know if I'll get this uploaded or
not to the Internet and I'm grateful
that you guys tuned in less and if you
have is to listen but it's almost kind
of nice to have the simplicity you know
the family I'm staying with I walked out
and they're all just sitting in the
kitchen it's 11 o'clock at night we all
went to some carnival together over
in some town called Henry and we had a
nice time and you know people you can
funnel cakes and coughing up
confectioner's sugar and you know and
just riding rides you didn't know if
you're going to live or die on and
whatever and you get back home and you
don't know if the Internet is going to
work and your phone doesn't work you
just mill around in the kitchen and chat
share stories I don't know there's a
sense of families since the community in
the environment I don't get that out in
LA maybe it's just me I feel like a lot
of people don't know it's just different
style of life it's a little more feels a
little more Americana out here but what
does it mean what does it mean to be an
American I don't know what does it mean
you guys I want to know so hit the
hotline man I'm going to find the
hotline number that is nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three also
I'm going to tell you guys just to two
dates I got coming up that's it
not going to bombard you I got Nashville
this weekend the 7th and 8th Friday and
Saturday at Zanies
one show each night KOCO Diaz threw it
up on his Twitter support me Sarah Tiana
supporting me getting a lot of good
support and I need you guys out there
please if you have friends in Nashville
send them out in Orlando next weekend
I'll be in Orlando the 13th through the
16th of the improv that's beautiful
check that out also July 20th I'll be in
San Diego July 20 W in San Diego with
Sal for Impractical Jokers and Roy Wood
jr. and
that that's at the House of Blues and
then surprise I'm going to Montreal just
for laughs and that'll be the 27th
through the 30th of July I'll be in
Montreal so I'm excited but look guys
I'm not going to make this a long
episode I want to know that's what I'm
going to leave it at what does it mean
to be an American to you these days your
happy 4th of July - you know I think
back on regrets on my life I have a few
you know boys had some time I've been
extremely hard on myself most of my life
you know I didn't probably treat my
mother with respect all the time I
didn't know how to but but still I don't
I don't take that no account some time
that it didn't and I didn't serve I
didn't serve didn't serve in the
military
I still could possibly you know National
Guard or someone they will see but but I
didn't so it just makes you wondering
what does it mean to be an American to
you so hit the hotline drop some of
those calls I'm going to do an episode
on Thursday a full episode it's going to
come out on Thursday and we're going to
get some point of views on that you know
is the idea of you know it's our America
and we got to know who's here and shut
the borders down and take a head count
and get out of national debt and become
a you know a country that everybody can
actually that will be here in 20 years
is that is that an okay old ideal or is
it old fashioned or is a new fashion
when you'd open the borders and let
everybody in and you know America just
goes as far as it can go until we're
bankrupt
you know until whatever country comes in
and once the cash is cheque and with
their money back and when they come and
take our land and then that's it is that
the way it goes
or both those ideas near-sighted by me
who knows I want to know what you think
so hit that hotline man
dang it I'm having fun right now but a
lot of you guys know what it is it's
nine eighty five I don't know it
you know I just don't know it but you
know it you can find it hit the hotline
come out support the show you can find
all my tour dates at Theo von comm slash
tour happy fourth of July man you know
make sure you call somebody in the
military who served
and just tell them thanks that's what
I'm going to do always hit up some of my
buddies even if they're squirrelly you
know and I'm just gonna try to remember
to have some gratitude because I live in
the greatest country on Earth
everyone's act like they don't go go to
another place and have the opportunities
you're going to have here I'd love to
see it go do what you want to do the
simple fact in America you can even make
fun of our President or bash you know
our Vice President or any people I don't
care who they are you know I don't care
if it's Reagan or Trump or for Clinton
or anybody this is simple fact you can
say what you want here can't do that
everywhere you know I'm just angry I
guess I'm just a little confused I'm
also tired I'm also sitting in the damn
Nissan Select out here in the middle of
the nowhere but part of it feels
kind of good man part of it just feels
good to be here here in Americana dude
there's a pony in the distance there's a
pony okay and I've eaten pony
dude and part of me just wonders if that
thing in the distance can still smell it
on my breath I'll see you guys on
Thursday man all right
Spencer Jacob growl band
[Music]
celebrate living it's the edge your
version some fun well we rely thank you
guys man for the love and support man
thank you guys for supporting and
Wyoming helped me raise some money when
I raised some money and I'll see you
guys I'll see you guys on Thursday with
a full episode we're going to crack into
it we're coming in hot
there's some hot new stuff is going to
be happening on the pond I'm excited
we're looking for some studio space
right now to get into a home and we can
get a produce or really just start to
get some stuff up to the next level
but but I'm grateful man I'm grateful
happy fourth of July
happy America and and love yourself man
take care of yourself I bet you deserve
it talk to you soon man good night
a good day Paul Harvey good very